we certainly saw a lot of that smoke
yesterday haze
still lingering from those wildfires
burning in california and boy that smoke
yesterday
just terrific it impacts our air quality
and of course our health
hector mejia is live this morning to
explain what doctors
and the national weather service are
saying good morning hector
taylor cheryl this wind is picking up
right now our van was shaking just a few
minutes ago and with
some daylight hours we are getting a
better view of all that thick smoke out
there in the distance right now as the
sun rises
the bottom portion of the horizon is a
lot darker than the higher elevations
that's how thick the smoke is
and you'll feel those fine particles in
your eyeballs as the wind blows the
smoke around
and today is supposed to get a lot
better once the wind picks up even more
and clears out the smoke
but that wind can also be a bad thing by
fueling the
out of state fires a lot of smoke
traveled from california to the las
vegas area yesterday
an ominous scene to watch it almost
looked like the smoke was swallowing the
sun
as california battles a historic
wildfire season local doctors say
that drifting smoke can have huge health
impacts on people in town
especially the elderly and those with
respiratory issues
not only is it more difficult to just
try to breathe normally it could also
trigger things like
asthma attacks and things that would
potentially cause people to go to the
hospital
but there may be some relief on the
horizon
we're gonna be seeing a cold front move
through and that should blow a lot of
this smoke
south of us and out of the area but
because we have so many fires ongoing
not just in california but some in utah
and some in other parts of the western
united states
it may we may see smoke again before
it's all over with
the national weather service here in las
vegas adds that the skies will likely
clear out today once that cold front
keeps moving in and then the question
will be will we see the smoke return
from any of the fires that are still
burning and back out here live here's a
live view of what the downtown area
looks off in the distance it looks more
like fog than anything but visibility
man it's pretty hard to see we can't
even see the mountains off in the
distance
we'll give you another look in about
half an hour from now but sherry
just another thing to add to the list of
bizarre things here
in 2020 right absolutely hector yeah and
those uh
smoke and that haze now getting also a
good taste of some dust getting picked
up by those big winds
that have hit us just instantly here in
the last 20 minutes or so this is
actually a look at the airport
but you can barely see the tower out
there those northeasterly winds
almost instantaneously up to 25 to near
30 miles an hour
the wind advisory in effect right now
and that was the forecast
that it would start at 6 a.m and it is
right on target this morning now